what's going on everyone i've got a
special uh presentation for you today
this is gonna be a little bit more
advanced stuff
um and it's because i'm partially making
this for my team
uh on the marketing side so one of the
things that i have found has been a
consistent source of new marketing for
us
is understanding data and so i think
some people are much better at telling
stores than i am
but i'm pretty decent at slicing data
and so
um the nice thing is that there's always
new inferences that you can derive from
data that you can make the same thing
mean different things
and so for example i'll give you some
statistics that we have
um that we've based entire campaigns
around so uh
one campaign that was our most
successful campaign that we've ever run
was a one year later campaign and so
what that was was
we took all of our clients that have
been with us for over a year and
measured all of their stats
and measured their status from before
they were with us until now a year later
and showed the difference right and the
the differences were crazy you know 250
000 500 000 or a million dollars here
extra like there's just massive
differences
and so from that from that one you know
measuring
example there's so many different sub
divisions of data that you can use right
you can just say hey when your later
average client is up this right that
would be
one way to do the data another way to do
that would be like
one year later our top twenty percent of
clients have added over four hundred
thousand dollars
a year uh to their yearly revenue
another one would be
uh the bottom you know eighty percent or
at this right
um and so there's there's all these are
like one in here's another way of doing
it
one in five gyms uh who's been with us
over a year
is at is over z right and so there's
different variables that you can play
with right
one is the percentage of people right
the next is the goal
and then the next is the duration piece
so you have these kind of three wheels
that you can spin together
uh to make really interesting statistics
and you can and you can
you can base so many campaigns around it
like another campaign that we have
that's launching soon is
um we just we just measured one in 5.5
gyms is over a million dollar a year run
rate
for us right and so all these you know
so for me it's easy because like you
know other people are like seven figure
j and blah blah blah and so for me i'm
like well they're talking about it we're
doing it right
and so i can always position myself
because most people don't even capture
their own data anyway so they don't even
know and it's usually because it's not
good right they already know they don't
have any million dollar gym so they
don't need to go measure that right
we do know it's a one in 5.5 that's 18
now if you're thinking about from
marketing perspective would you think
18 percent of gyms that we work with are
seven figure gems
maybe i don't think that sounds as
compelling as one in 5.5 like really one
in five like that's not that bad
right and the thing is is you can also
invert that and say all right
but 4.5 out of 5.5 gyms hit
this right so it's like i can play on
the
on the on the the desire that people
have to win the lottery
survivorship bias like that people think
they're going to be the one
right but i can also play on the inverse
which is something that i like doing a
lot which is i love playing on averages
i love playing on medians
um with data because it's like hey this
is just what the normal person does
right like and here's what's cool you
can always say after you say an average
that also means half of people are above
this
we're like wow well i consider myself
above average so i'm going to be above
that because everyone thinks they're
above average right
and so when you're clumping data
together you can use those three wheels
right wheel one is
over what duration wheel two is what is
the um
what is the outcome um and then i
literally can't even remember what the
oh and then the percentage of clients
that achieve that right so it's
percentage of clients the outcome and
then the time duration
and so you have these wheels that you
can mix and match and even when you say
percentage of clients
you can say percentage of clients you
can say the top percentage the bottom
percentage the median the average
right um and you can also say one in
right so there's different different
ways you can also say the fractional
version like one-fifth of
right so all of these are that's just
like that was just on the one wheel
of um what percentage of clients right
what percentage one-fifth one in however
many
the fractional amount the top percent is
the bottom percentage so you can invert
either one of those
so one in five or four out of five right
that would be the inversion the same
stat
and so when i'm using all of that like
this is what i'm running through and
this is what i've had a really hard time
teaching my team which is why i'm making
this right now
um is that like this is what i'm running
through what i'm thinking when i'm
looking at like the
the data they get back from customer
support or excuse me customer success
is like this they're like here's here's
all the gyms that we have i'm like okay
how can we say this differently how can
we say this in a compelling way
and make it a hook for our marketing
right um
and so that was that was all the
examples i had for uh percentage of
clients right
now if we're talking uh time duration
right so with time duration
i'm like i'm gonna be thinking uh super
long long
long time away and here's what's cool
about when you use long longer durations
away if someone's been with you for a
year the likelihood that they've
succeeded is very high especially in
education-based business
so i i love pulling out the one year or
two year later pieces because one
it shows that people stay with me for a
long time which means that i continually
provide value
right so that's social proof of
continued value creation which i like a
lot
so boom when you have the long term
duration it's great that's an advantage
especially if you're an older player in
the space
having those one year two year later
testimonials is something that no one
else can show
that you can show to also demonstrate
your long-standingness in the space
right
but on top of that somebody's been with
you for that long is going to usually
have a very good outcome
and so if i just say hey the people
who've been with me for over a year
average this
that it's like wow that's crazy right
and so the data will
will give a very positive impression
of what you're marketing right flip side
um
is that you can cut it at different
different times right you can look at
first week you can look at first 30 days
you can look at
first two months right and so the thing
is is if you have this data on a regular
basis
uh you can you can time stamp this stuff
and really
you can slice it and find that the slice
that you're like oh this is really good
like
for us like our average gym in the first
uh
i think this first 15 days not 15 days
excuse me first two weeks just fifteen
thousand five hundred
all right uh an additional round that's
the average which means half people get
better than that
right crazy and so um and i i give you
the other stat earlier one in 5.5 gyms
is a million dollar gym
right and so i'm i can play with these
you know
with these numbers because i could have
said 18 or i could have said with the
percent of the the 15 500 i could say
that's a
what's the outcome right the outcome
wheel could be what's the increase
right if it was the increase it might be
like the average person
you know doubles what they do in revenue
in the first 14 days
that's a different way of saying it
right um i don't know what i don't know
what the actual number is because i
don't have that one offhand but like
that would be something that i'd be
that's something i'd ask my team i'd be
like hey
figure out what the fraction is here is
it a doubling is it a 1.5 x is it a 30
increase well 30 increase doesn't sound
as good as 15 500 right
so i'm going to say that one instead and
so when we're talking about increases
there's four ways you can show it one is
a a percent increase which is this went
up by x percent right
the next is an absolute increase which
is additional 15
500 right um the next would be uh
the actual total number made which would
be
their revenue plus the increase boom
right
which would be different but similar
right uh so you've got the
the just the increase you've got the
total amount made you've got the
percentage increase
you've got a relative increase which is
one that i like which is
what is 15 500 buy you right so
15 hundred might be like um i would have
to look up industry averages but i'd say
the
you know maybe industry average for uh a
micro gym
rent might be let's say two thousand
dollars a month so i'd say in the first
30 days
the average gym in our program pays off
three quarters or nine months of rent
wow that sounds kind of interesting
right like that's
that's compelling that's unique right so
hopefully you're following along with me
you're like
the three big wheels right wheel number
one you've got is
what's the outcome well wheel number two
is the time duration and wheel number
three is what percentage of clients you
know achieve this outcome
and so when you're playing with these
three wheels and you're slicing the data
all of these wheels have variables which
is why you can slice data in so many
different directions
but for me this is usually what i will
search for
like this is what i will hunt for i will
look
for the piece of data that tells the
story
that that that the copy can't tell or it
can reinforce
the story that the copy tells and makes
it far more compelling right now mind
you
you have to be absolutely compliant when
you use numbers right which is one of
the things i also like doing it because
we track our stuff and most of our you
know most people in our space
don't because they're you know still
figuring out how to you know market and
figure out their business but the thing
is most people don't track this stuff
and so i have a huge advantage because
i've been tracking this stuff for years
right
and on top of that we have we have
pretty decent um metrics around this
stuff especially around client success
and so with that i can hunt and say okay
let's look at uh new clients you know
first first eight weeks right what's how
much what's the increase in revenue okay
and the thing is is everything i just
talked about was one stat
right i just talked about revenue i
could use the same three wheels with
time
uh the customer outcome and then what
percentage of them achieved it
i could use those same three wheels with
any of the stats i could use it with
profit i could use it with revenue i
could use it with churn i could use it
with
um i could even use it with growth
percentage
right i could use it with like there's
there's so many different ways i can i
can use those three wheels in my
marketing
but usually this will be the central
core concept
that i will make an entire campaign
around right because at the end of the
day there's only so many ways for me to
say we make gyms more money
right like i mean and the thing is at
the end of the day everyone promises
that so the question is how can i make
um a different more unique promise and
how can i make
it more compelling and believable
that they will achieve it right and so
that's kind of why i use data as
most of the times the central selling
point that i have
for any program that i sell now the good
thing is is that
and i've always done it that way because
i'm usually when we're convicted because
it's it's easy to have conviction in
stats because those are what they are so
i can have
absolute conviction that this is what it
is so take it or leave it these are the
stats right like you can choose you know
if i said
my you know my weight loss program has
an 87 success rate uh
people hitting you know over 15 pounds
then then like me even like how about
this
i'll say it even differently let's say
let's say i had a let's say my success
rate of people hitting
over i have a i have a 70 success rate
of people hitting over
12 pounds lost in the first six weeks
with me right
there's two variables that i'm playing
actually three again which is
what percentage of customers achieve x
result right and i can change x result
because i said what percentage customers
achieve over
over 30 pounds lost it'd be much smaller
it'd only be like 10
right and sometimes it's worth saying
the top 10 of our clients hit x i think
it works better with business stuff but
like in a weight loss scenario that
would be that would be an example
it's like i have this percentage of
customers to achieve this percent and i
can move
these right until i find a sweet spot
where i look in the data and i'm like
huh
70 of our clients hit over
16 pounds lost that's pretty good right
in this period of time and so now i can
start marketing that because i have the
data to support it and substantiate it
right
and so when i'm thinking about new hooks
right here's a different one that i ran
that crushed it for us
which is i told you earlier about the
5.5 gyms
one of 5.5 gyms is a million dollar gym
here's another way you can do it with
the time i didn't even get into the time
duration one yet
is that i can say one in uh every excuse
me
every x days x minutes x
hours x weeks x months we achieve a y
right and so i found out because i
looked at our stats and i think the the
last year we had done
gosh i don't know it was like i honestly
can't remember the number but i do
remember the outcome it was
um i think we created like 50 something
uh seven-figure gyms in 2019
or 2020 something like that anyways
point is is we created that many
and i was like well there's 52 weeks in
a year that means that
one in every 7.7 days we create another
seven-figure gym
so that means every basically every week
we're cranking out another
seven-figure gym so it takes the idea of
like this is how many
of these outcomes we've had right so
again in that weight loss example i
could say
how many people have we had lose you
know 20 pounds right over
you know over the last year and they
might say you know we've had [ __ ] we've
had we've had 200 people hit that
i'd be like cool so we can say every two
days
another person crosses 20 pounds lost at
my facility
wow isn't that a different way of saying
x percent of people hit this goal in
experience
right so there's there's these different
ways of slicing it um and so i would
implore you and this is also for my team
that when we're when we're looking at
what our main hook our main
messaging that we're gonna wrap the
whole campaign around um is let's look
at the data
right and let's think about the three
wheels what's the outcome
uh what percentage people hit it over
what time duration and then play with
all of them
right with the time duration it's one in
every how many days every how many
minutes
how many whatever is it is it over one
year is it in the first 30 days in the
first six weeks
you know whatever like is that that's
the time duration the customer
i already said all the million ways of
slicing the the outcome
um and the percentage right and so
hopefully that makes sense for you hope
you found that valuable
um they'll probably give you unlimited
ways of slicing your own data
but i'm telling you it's one of the most
compelling things in the world because
it's just true
so i'll leave you with that keep being
awesome that was a
huge marketing hack that has made me a
tremendous amount of money so
use it and uh be fruitful bye